it's great to welcome to the program
today Anna Muldoon who is a former
science policy adviser at the Department
of Health and Human Services currently a
PhD student at Arizona State University
studying infectious disease and social
crisis so great to talk to you today so
I recently read an article by a Turkish
author I actually forget their name but
it talked about some of the social
similarities that have taken place as
infectious disease has spread in
different times in in sort of moderately
recent human history that denial is
often an initial reaction from places
outside the initial sort of perceived
source that scapegoating is very common
finding some initial group or country or
whatever right now there's a lot of talk
of China Jews were blamed for the plague
in times past etc etc and also the idea
sort of of the disease as a personal
failing a human failing of some kind
which can take some different forms
maybe we can start there like what what
are the general trends that you have
studied and seen over time related to
infectious disease so you nailed a lot
of them there actually you know disease
as a personal failing is a really old
conception and disease as punishment is
a really old concept it we've had that
embedded in particularly Western
Christian culture for a very very long
time
going all the way back to the Bible
plagues plagues and Pharaoh but also all
through European history as infectious
disease appeared and disappeared there
were moments where it was viewed as
punishment from God for social sins
punishment of the individual for
individual sins and as we moved into a
sort of more secular moment
that has transformed really in the 19th
and 20th centuries into sort of
individual punishment for some
behavioral failing whatever that might
be so sometimes it is you know drinking
or partying too much cholera 19th
century collar was blamed on European
immigrants who were sort of a bit more
lively than their counterparts in New
York City and then were blamed for
having cholera saying it was spread
either by beer or occasionally by
communion wine that one was interesting
and then sort of as infectious disease
has spread this time we've seen a lot of
people talking about New Orleans and you
know Mardi Gras being the spot that
spread it through New Orleans because
those people needed to party which is
not really totally fair to New Orleans
and it's it's still very present I think
in the ways that we talk about kovat and
the ways that we have talked about
disease spread now and really for the
past several thousand years
unfortunately the idea not just of the
disease as punishment for sin but of
Prayer maybe as a protector how far back
does that go I mean we recently saw this
video of a woman leaving a mega church
where she said she's covered in the
blood of Jesus so she's fine
and so on and so forth that I'm guessing
that's also not new know also not new
very much not new it's what's
interesting is that it it the ways that
that worked kind of pre-reformation are
a little bit different and it was more
kind of prayer covering the whole
community but also a sort of acceptance
that disease was part of life now and in
particular in the United States there
have been fights about national prayer
too
epidemics all the way back to the 18th
century right in 1721 the there was a
large smallpox outbreak in Boston and
there are fights about prayer and
predestination as they begin to
introduce inoculation and whether you
should simply pray that you survive
because if you're a good person you'll
survive or whether you should take this
inoculation which at that moment was
viewed as possibly you know violating
predestination by messing with the plan
and then in the 1830s and 1850s with
cholera on the east coast of the United
States there are some impressively
intense fights about national prayer to
prevent the epidemic that in some cases
actually threatened to unseat a variety
of politicians and turn into political
issues as well as religious issues so
that one's old and very embedded in
American culture so for me this is a
part of at least right now seeing the
current administration's handling of the
virus at least over the last month
really as a cultural war rather than a
medical war and I did a segment about
this earlier this week my perspective is
that they've essentially failed on the
medical war so they're making it about
culture and values which are much more
pliable in terms of empirically
determining what it is that's going on
and so masks have become a signal of
your perspective as to what's going on
open versus closed has become an issue
of government tyranny and so on and so
forth is this the way this often goes
where it becomes a culture war hmm
you know honestly having studied a lot
of disease history I would say that this
kind of polarization of responding to
disease is fairly unusual
the fights so the fights around
infectious disease do often fall on
cultural lines right
so there's there's an author I love
called de certeau who talks about the
ways that in that in certain moments the
things that underlie society the
detentions that are already there kind
of break apart and come to light he
talks about these tensions that exist
that we all live inside sort of rising
up from under the streets it's a
beautiful passage but I think the
commonality among infectious disease
outbreaks is that they intensify and
make very visible social decision social
divisions social tensions and existing
problems but rarely do you see this kind
of pretending that a disease just
doesn't exist in communities where it
does it's I obviously am studying this
as I'm working on it
because it's both fascinating and a
little disturbing - what do you
attribute it I mean why it seems too
simplistic to say well it's because of
Trump I mean he seems to be the one who
is at the top of the federal government
right now but there's some element of
society allowing that to take place as
well right absolutely I think that
America for a long time has been deeply
divided along urban and rural lines and
that has very much played out in kovat
where the early outbreaks were very much
in urban areas where people travel more
and it's only now that they're really
moving into rural areas so for a long
time the pattern of kovat in the country
actually exemplified that division
I think the America has for a long time
had some intense class division among
types of workers and that is also very
much playing out here where a lot of the
a lot of workers some
can't stay home and so for those who can
responding to the disease is a different
type of ask right asking me to work from
home on history historical stuff or
policy is a very different ask than
asking that of someone who works in a
factory we're working from home isn't an
option so some of it I think is also
about the ways people have to justify
their own need to you know eat and
continue working and feed their families
and then some of it is the intense
polarization that we've experienced over
really the past ten years I think the
divisions in what news we watch what
radio shows we listen to you what
newspapers we read have really made it
possible for there to be multiple worlds
based on the same information in a way
that just hasn't historically always
been true when it comes to talking now
about stigma of disease itself there's
certain diseases that have more social
stigma attached to them so certainly
sexually transmitted infections and
diseases would be one category within
cancer lung cancer sometimes generates
less sympathy because it can be
connected to the bad act of smoking
cigarettes as an example where does the
where do these types of pandemics that
like coronavirus kind of fit into the
stigma analysis so I wish I wish dearly
that I could tell you that pandemic
disease was an exemption from stigma
unfortunately I could I don't get to say
that so it's lower on the scale than
things like STDs or lung cancer higher
on the scale than zero so you're
starting to see problems where people
have recovered from Kovan and are having
difficulty still getting ambulances to
to their house or their neighbors don't
want them to leave the house or want
them to move out if the neighborhood's
businesses where the owner has recovered
where no one will go inside because
they're afraid of the virus and I think
that that is something we will probably
see expanding there has also
unfortunately been a lot of
racialization of this virus that has
caused serious problems in a lot of
Chinese American communities but also
unfortunately other Asian American
communities that isn't so much disease
stigma as disease blame and kind of
racialization of the disease so I think
that those are those are things that we
as a society and as a nation need to
consciously combat and pay attention to
you because know someone that were
covered from kovat four months ago is
not going to give you the virus but
people are still afraid it's one of the
ways where the stigma is entering a
little more is with some of the reports
that for example of the younger people
that are dying overwhelmingly they are
obese and obesity is often associated
with you know moral failings rather than
medical conditions so it seems maybe
that's one way in which it's creeping in
lately oh yeah
I actually started my the first year and
a half I was in public health I was
doing research on obesity stigma I found
infectious disease to be a less
depressing topic and tells you think
about how bad it is yeah I think the
absolutely a lot of the things about
pre-existing conditions are allowing
people to blame those who've died of
kovat for their own deaths which is
deeply frustrating you know most of the
most of the pre-existing conditions that
really predispose people to dying from
kovin are those that are really
frequently linked to structural factors
in economics in race in
access to medical care in location and
so it is kind of quadruply frustrating
to then watch them become a way to
write-off covet deaths because they're
almost entirely structurally linked
comorbidities I guess this is the best
way to put it
yeah no question about that and that's
often missing from you know the science
science can tell us a lot of the facts
but it doesn't it rarely tells us about
the economic and sociological factors
that kind of led to those being being
the facts we've been speaking with
animal Doon who's a former science
policy advisor at the Department of
Health and Human Services Anna so great
to speak to you I really appreciate your
time course